I'm going to give you my three favorite
questions that I ask when I'm making
bets in the business to make the most
money.
And I have these as almost like my
treasured prized possessions because of
how useful and how valuable the thinking
frames they provide are.
And so I'll give you conditions for each
using each of these three.
So the first is
when someone wants me to do something or
they want me to approve of an action,
I will almost always
respond with, "What problem are you
trying to solve?"
And what's really interesting about that
question is that a lot of times people
have this emotional discomfort, there's
a problem that happens
or they just don't feel good which they
determine is a problem. And then as a
result their actions skew all over the
place.
They're like, "Hey, I think we should do
this employee engagement program." I'm
like, "Okay, what problem are you trying
to solve?"
Um well, I just thought it'd be good for
the employees. So I'm like, "Well, do we
have a retention issue? Do we have an
attraction issue? Are we unable to
attract talent? Like let me know cuz
that's very important." And they're
like, "No, no, no, we we don't have any
retention issues or we don't have any
attraction issues." And it's like,
"Okay,
then why are we doing this?"
Well, I think it's good.
What problem are we trying to solve?
And so I would say that I've I've
learned this this this problem question
because
there's people people are erratic. They
want to do stuff. And so what ends up
happening is well-intentioned people,
nothing wrong with that,
um
they will
just take action
on things that they know how to do when
they are confronted with things that
they do not know how to do. And so a lot
of lack of focus is actually
intellectual laziness.
So what I mean is I think most people in
their business know on some level what
needs to happen. But, because they don't
know how to solve that thing, they then
just find something they can solve
because that makes them feel better and
more competent, even though it makes no
difference. And so, like I would
encourage you to think, "If I am being
distracted, it means I'm being
intellectually lazy because I can't stay
on this task that I don't know how to
accomplish and be incompetent for any
period in order to get what I want,
right? And so, it's a it's a great suss
out of the thinking diligence that the
person who's asking you to do something
or about your willing to make or that
they asking you to make or take.
Um whether they actually really thought
it through. So, number one, someone asks
you me to do something, what problem are
you trying to solve?
If I'm asking someone to do something,
so I want something now.
I ask the question instead of giving the
statement. I'll say, "What would it
take?"
And so, I almost always wrap my
questions with what would it take
because it assumes success.
And what happens is when I used to ask,
and this is something I did earlier in
my career, "Can we? Could we?"
Um I would get no's from people and they
would do a calculus in their mind of
what they thought something was worth
without complete context on my business
like I have or complete context for the
plans that I have long term for the
business. And then they would basically
make a decision on my behalf by saying
no.
So, I actually have I'm I'm actually
working off of incorrect data. Like this
is really important Even though I
like I'm, you know, just making a little
webcam version here, but like really
really important. This is how my brother
and I got a a conversation about this.
Um
If I asked, "What would it take?"
someone can then just tell me what it
would take and then I can make the
decision of whether I think it's worth
it.
And so, that the amount of things that
have been unlocked in my business of me
just saying, like, someone says no, I'm
like, stop. What would it take for us to
do it? Obviously, if I had a billion
dollars, could I do it? They're like,
well, yeah. I'm like, okay, does it take
a billion dollars? Like, no. Okay, does
it take a million dollars? Okay, no. All
right, what does it actually take? We
probably need to hire somebody. Okay.
Well, it's going to make us an extra
million dollars this year, and it's
this, you know, whatever, 100 grand for
this person.
Okay, then let's do that. So, you're
just saying that we can't do it with our
existing infrastructure. Or, or
specifically, that the existing
infrastructure is prioritized against
other things, which I can then say,
let's deprioritize those and prioritize
this.
Right?
So, if someone asks me, let's do this
thing, I like to ask, what problem are
we solving?
If I want something, I ask other people,
what would it take?
What would it take for us to do this in
half the time? What would it take for us
to deliver this in 24 hours instead of
uh 30 days? What would it take for us to
buy this company? What would it take for
us to to do this deal? What would it
take for you to get started today? What
would it take for me to get you to
believe that you should shut down one of
your businesses uh in a and go all in on
the other? What would it take for me, or
what would it take for you to to take
our content from 10 things a day to 20
things a day? What would it take?
It is the one of the most powerful
questions in entrepreneurship.
Now,
the third question that I'll give you is
related to question number one, which is
when people ask me, you know, like, hey,
I think we should do this thing.
Um I would say my first follow-up to
whatever the response is, cuz sometimes
people don't know the problem they're
trying to solve.
Um is I just ask,
so, this is question three, what do you
want to have happen?
And I'm saying these questions, and I
feel like my team, you know, will be
listening to this and be like, yeah, I
mean, he says those questions a lot.
What do you want to have happen?
Because it just gets around all of the
like emotional hullabaloo to just what
do you want to see?
And the reason this is important, you
know, like let's say let's use a
different example. Uh someone says,
"Hey,
I think we should make a video about
whatever. Or not. Let's Let's use a
better example.
Um
I think we should start doing our
quarterly release in person.
Okay. Let's say you're a remote company.
Someone says, "I think we should start
doing our quarterly in person." I say,
"Okay, what do you want to have happen?"
Well, I mean, I I want, you know, the
quarterly to be in person. Yeah, yeah,
but like as a result of these quarterly
in person, what do you want to have
happen?
What different outcome will occur as a
result of in-person versus remote
quarterlies?
Well, I think, you know, I think it'll
it'll be it'll be more fun. Okay, so the
argument would be that you think that
people will be more engaged in person
versus online. Okay, no argument there.
Do we think that their engagement in
terms of how much fun they're having has
anything to do with their output
afterwards? Again, I ask these questions
not because I they're loaded or because
I disagree with them. I'm curious cuz I
want to hear the other person's
thinking. And so
when I'm questioning this these lines of
thinking, I will typically ask three in
succession, which is
what does that mean?
How do you know that? And so what?
So if I say, "Hey, uh you want to get,
you know, the employees to be more
engaged." I'm like, "Okay, what does
engaged mean? What does that mean?"
I'm like, "Oh, well, I just, you know, I
think I think they'll be happier at
work." Okay, what does that mean?
Okay, like tell me. Like Like what does
that even What does that even mean? Like
we're going to their subjective
well-being scores are going to go up?
Okay.
Question two, how do you know that?
Do we want to give them a subjective
well-being test where they rate their
happiness before and then we have them
rate their happiness afterwards and then
we see if this made a demonstrable
difference?
Yeah? Okay, I understand. You want them
to be happier and you want this. Okay,
question three.
So what? Let's say we do this. Then what
happens?
Do we think that it'll have to dim like
it'll diminish once once they leave?
Maybe.
Do we think this is going to have
something on worker output? Okay, I have
this research that suggests that worker
output goes up by X, Y, and Z. And so
it's like, "Okay.
Now, the final question for me would be
like, what else could we do with this
time and energy that would yield a
higher return to the business?"
And to be clear, I obviously want my
people to be happy. I don't think that
these one-off things are actually what
make people happy. I think that having
an ongoing work environment that rewards
high effort and removes people who suck
is a much more effective way of getting
people to enjoy their work
uh than kind of, you know, Kumbaya
Um but I say this as as just a
just to equip you cuz I see I see
questions like weapons. Like
it's like it shows it shows how sharp
your thinking is.
On both sides. Like if someone asks me
these questions just what I mean. I've
had some some people on my team uh ask
me like, "Well, uh well, what do you
mean by that?" And they're they're
trying to use my weapons at me and I'm
like, "Bro, I can tell you what I mean
because I thought about it."
And so
like these questions, though they appear
difficult, allow you to suss out or
determine the quality or depth of
someone's thinking around a problem or
solution set.
And
I would say that I use these on a
regular basis when making bets in the
business where I think we will get high
returns.
And if I want this to happen and then I
say, "What would it take for this to
happen?" I get a very different set of
answers from people that tends to create
more divergent thinking processes, as in
they try to solve
for success and reverse engineer it. And
when I open up the blue ocean of like,
let's say we had unlimited money and
unlimited time, what would it take?
And then all of a sudden you go from
unlimited time to unlimited money, and
then what it would actually would take
is, you know, well, unlimited is
unlimited, right? But like, there are
small percentages uh in relation to
that.
And so anyways, this was top of mind
because I had a handful of conversations
yesterday that were that were in
relation to this, where people would
say, "I want to do this thing." It's
like, "What problem are we trying to
solve?"
What do you want to have happen?
What does that mean? How do you know
that's going to happen when you do that?
And even if we do, so what?
Who cares? What What does this affect?
How does this connect to a business
outcome?
And what you'll find is a lot of these
questions lead to maybe we shouldn't do
this, and that's usually the right
answer. And so one of my internal uh
jokes that I have is the undefeated
heavyweight champion of the world is do
nothing. Like when I have like three
doors of action, do A, you know, you
know,
do A, do B, and then do nothing.
Do nothing so commonly is the correct
answer. As in, nope, continue to re- you
know, continue to allocate resources
towards the things that are getting the
highest return. This is a thing that
might get us a return, but we have this
other thing that we know will get us a
return, and the return that we get here
might be as good, but this one is
certainly will be, and so we should just
do more of that.
So,
right now, when you're contemplating uh
you know, should I should I do this
thing, this you know, somebody on my
team or I I'm the one who's suggesting
these things,
you might have suggested it because you
are emotionally
uncomfortable with your existing moment
and just want something to do rather
than the thing that you know is going to
work. So anyways, uh Uh, those are a of
questions that I use like weapons that
have helped me make better bets. Uh, I
hope they help you.
>> If you like this video and you're a
business owner who wants to break
through your current revenue ceiling, I
just did every lesson from scaling 10
businesses past 10 million and three
businesses past 100 million into a
completely free scaling roadmap that
I've used to go from zero to one, zero
to 10, and zero to 100 plus. And so you
can click here and you can check it out.
Again, absolutely free. And since you're
a business owner, appreciate you and
enjoy.